nos invités nous ont rejoints pour
parler capoeira bâtisse colombani
bonjour vous êtes venu avec votre maître
maître touchés bonjour à jour merci à
tous les deux d'être là sur le plateau
alors vous va ensemble à bord d un grand
événement qui se passe ce week-end
serait l'encours ce sont les 10e
rencontres internationales de capoeira
que vous organisez m touchées chaque
année depuis dix ans puisque ça fait dix
ans que vous êtes en france c'est le
brésilien bien sûr et donc dix ans vous
organiser ces rencontres là ça va être
du coup une rencontre particulière parce
que ça va être un peu votre anniversaire
ah oui bien sûr parce que la wii c'est
le dixième c'était très important pour
moi c'est tout ça je vous mettais pas
mal du monde pour participer avec moi et
donc aujourd'hui ça me fait plaisir
aussi d'y être là avec jour on se
parlait aux métiers pléthore d'acteurs
de la caporale et 10 ont glissé en
france et comme j'arrive ici
alors quand même et il ya beaucoup de
monde il ya quand même plus de 20 mètres
20 professeurs de caméras qui sont
invités qui vont à donner des stages en
fait oui oui ce héros est celle entre m
professeur ans trop tôt du caporal c'est
des professionnels des caméras qui sont
six ans comme moi aussi qui travaillent
donc et aujourd'hui ils sont lents si ça
commence aujourd'hui le vendredi sont
pas moins déjà contraint d'arriver
aujourd'hui cette commande déjà avec les
stages avec des professeurs qui vient
matériaux déjà suisse et l'italie reçoit
et la semaine de france nord de la
france et a des maux cissé démarre le
matin par de petits stages et à partir
de 16h se démarre le baptême que baptême
c'est un condo élèves
il va pour sa première garde d'achat
alors pour qu'on me comprenne un peu
plus la capoeira en gros ce sont des
arts martiaux vous me dire si je me
trompe des arts martiaux qui vient qui
viennent du brésil alors s'est inspiré
de
de quelle quelles sont les origines de
cabrera ou esprit ses origines
africaines
mehdi c africain s'était réfugié au
brésil donc à partir de là elles vont
crier la capoeira ton comme les livres
les îles docteurs ont dit que c'était un
faux brésilienne voilà qui fera dans mon
moi elle vient d'origine africaine mon
coeur aujourd'hui on fait pas mal et on
cotise aussi à me vendre novembre
c'était la date et d'un scandale sur la
vertu à son esclave aussi donc là moi
c'est entre le combat et la danse un
petit peu pour simplifier
oui oui c'est entre les combats et la
danse la danse c'est parce qu'en fait
petit part parce qu'on écoute la musique
qui en fait petit pas aussi qu'on
appelle des gigas et boxer on peut plus
cacher que c'est l'époque engagé en se
cachant métier plus ratio puisque avait
même pas montre élite et que le vrai
vrai avec un vrai cap heures donc mais
la caporale aujourd'hui j'ai dit que
c'est un véritable par mois ci alors je
me tende vers les verts baptiste qu'est
ce qui vous a attiré vous dans la
capoeira comment vous avez connu des
jacobins
j'ai connu en fait on était tout un
groupe d'amis puis touchés avec déjà
deux élèves quittaient deux amis puis ou
alors on a rentré tous ensemble pour
être mon sens dans notre sport puis avec
le temps on se retrouvait plus qu'à deux
là mais non ce qui m'a beaucoup plu déjà
c'est tous les mouvements artistiques et
où tout ça puisque c'est un sport
complet on demande de savoir jouer des
instruments de savoir chanter faisait à
partir d'une certaine corde il faut
savoir quand les brésiliens genia cours
de langue cours de musique un petit peu
critique aujourd'hui la caporale un
espoir qu'on pourrait donc il ya tout un
petit peu de tout ça se promet
ogiwara cia et sport physique c'est de
la danse donc la musique le chant temps
donc un espoir très très bien apprécié
par le public et je pouvais dix ans
aujourd'hui depuis dix ans je suis j'ai
des petits dés entre l'asie 4 ont alors
on commence à 84 au donc après ces
quatre ans que bâti vous avez commencé
avec les autres en 13 ans quand même
c'est en vaunage 300 pour commencer mon
petit geophys les à 2 ans elle est déjà
fait de quelques jours là on apprend à
ces petits bouts de chou du japon
appareil qu'on les a douté petty base
donc la gym gars en train de s'imposer à
zynga ont des mouvements artistiques
coût 10 pieds de sa tendance tout en
érigeant des p tit ans l'âge adulte
vous pouvez le faire alors par exemple
ce week end il reste des places pour les
stages
est-ce qu'on peut venir spontanément
pour participer au stage il faut
s'inscrire
déjà quand même avoir quelques bases oui
et bien sûr vous pouvez un papa du tour
pas besoin de savoir et tout pouvait
venir tout le monde la porte ouverte
tout le monde dehors qui voulaient
découvrir pollet qui fera donc là c'est
le moment donc là pas besoin qu'on est
rien du tout il n'y a pas besoin d être
qu'on veut dire un tout le monde pouvait
être l'arctic épauler faire dans mon cas
parce qu'elles en font que l'autre non
pas du tout simplement il faut lui ni
avec une idée qui va apprendre la
capture a donc vendredi et samedi ça se
passe à elancourt au palais des sports
où là il ya des stages et l'après midi
samedi après midi il ya aussi une
démonstration fait par les maîtres par
les professeurs oui est parti 16 heures
démonstration des enfants il y en à
monstres sont si des professeurs et
professionnels qui vient d ailleurs d
autres villes le montrer à votre rayon
seront faits c est que samedi soir c'est
la fête la la fiesta brésilienne manqué
la partie du 20 heures
vous êtes tous invités aussi à
participer avec nous ok cette cire
monique c'était bien avec combien
d'ouvriers la graduation que c'était la
première grade et l'epasa exacte des
élèves alors dit dimanche ça se passera
à créteil c'est la dernière et troisième
journée ce dimanche sur elle ses côtés
dont 94 comme je suis en plus partout la
capoeira est aujourd'hui admis ont pris
pas mal d aider des villes je suis dont
94 10 878 succès dont 92 alors que le
dimanche on va finir dimanche 194 la
cote évolue vais citer quand il croise
donc vous parler de grades de baptême je
me tourne vers les lèvres
donc vous avez quel grade comment ça
marche je vous avez une belle ceinture
en dix ans tu as une corde de ceinture
ceinture troisième module celle là ouais
je sais pas si on peut la voir je passe
pour l'avoir faudra la lgv est un petit
peu ouais super elle est jaune et bleu
c'est ça je n'ai guère fonceur univers
français d'accord alors ça veut dire
quoi ça c'est votre deuxième adulte
le troisième adultes puisque avaya tous
les grades enfants après les grades
adultes voilà ça c'est aujourd'hui vous
avez quel âge 19 ans ça fait six ans
ouais c'est ça et j'ai d'abord passé des
grades enfants certains et puis après je
suis passé un adulte voile et vous avez
envie de continuer ouais voyez comment
un peu dans l'univers de la capoeira
comment ouais est-ce que vous avez des
grades en perspective
est ce que vous imaginez pouvoir arrêter
la capoeira non pas pour le moment mais
non c'est pas ces patrons les options
d'arrêter les chemins possibles pouvoir
moi même donner des cours donc voilà
être m contre m ça serait bien déjà il
faut beaucoup de travail pour être
maître vous même vous êtes m oui moi se
mettre moi j'ai commencé on a six
courses et pétillant la sg 9 et 10 ans
donc on oublie que c'est toujours des
vignes et plus haut possible
aujourd'hui j'arrive et pas dans le
gradin maximum mais j'ai su bien
conscient que j'évite regrette des
maîtres oui ces jambons grade déjà donc
aujourd'hui ça me permette j'ai dû re
signer pro zié montrer avec les élèves
plus d'expérience mais que j'aime et qui
auront avant et j'ai des inscrits au
déjà donc là donc j'ai une question un
peu curieuse et maîtres toucher tout ça
c'est un pseudo n'est ce pas votre
vraiment bon en attendant vos noms que
chez c'était c'était dans une émission
d'été les complices attaché en fait
c'était un dessin animé mais ses membres
et c'est chez nous mais c'est le dessin
c'était un français c'était là c'était
un tortueux qui s'appelle touchés et
comme moi à l'époque j'ai bien j'aimais
bien jouer avec des épées et vu
quelqu'un de travailler dans radio j ce
qui m'a donné son nom j'ai environ 17
ont donc abandonné j'ai cultivé cette
somme toute ma vie on a aujourd'hui un
ca de nîmes est fauché le mot renoncer
marques ou marques d'accor est ce qu'on
est obligé de prendre un petit peu comme
ça des surnoms quand on passe m on sait
quelque chose de personnel avant que ces
bâtisses devient maître ès qui n'ont
cessé même pas vous pouvez donner savons
donc là par exemple et les sons sont
simples et non mais au bout de mon moi
doivent arriver quelqu'un mettre un
professeur qui trouveront sûrement bruit
en son nom sympa et donc la haye la daps
est son nom et à partir de là ils
commençaient les halles jusqu'à elle
mais sinon il n'y a pas de souci
professeur baptiste donc là c'est pas
dans ma cops est pas obligé il ya des
gens des autres écoles qui lassé obligé
dans le descendant direct de premières
jour du baptême
mais c'est son nom qui appelait va
disparaître c'est un peu tôt peut-être
le plus tôt c'est de lui au pied le
temps est passé et que la personne
d'arsène tournon et qui va devenir pour
toute sa vie alors comment est-ce qu'il
est comme professeur m touchés soit
exigeant exigeants ils exigent mais elle
vaut mieux mais mieux vaut mieux il nous
pousse à bout en fait jusqu'à ce qu'on
puisse plus et c'est bien parce que si
nous laisser faire ce qu'on voulait je
pense qu'on fera pas grand chose donc
fois du moins au début en tout cas mais
non est ce un bon prince et quelles sont
les difficultés à la capoeira
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui vous a posé
le plus de problème de savoir faire les
coups de pied bien et rapidement ça
c'est les faire vite et bien c'est c'est
dur surtout au début il ya des coups de
pied qui sont simples ne soit plus
compliqué les plus compliqués c'est
c'est ça met du temps à prendre après où
elle est souple ça met du temps aussi
soit plus on commence tard plus c'est
dur d'être sous de bon coeur
mais qu'est ce que vous préférez parce
que vous avez vous faut aussi apprendre
la langue faut pouvoir jouer aussi des
instruments quels sont les instruments
qu'on joue par exemple il ya trois
instruments il ya là tabak
c'est
au total sur sa percussion il ya le but
ringo et ya le prônent leur offre c'est
tout et qu'est ce que par exemple vous
préférez faire jouer donné des coups de
pied certaines chorégraphies certains
mouvements ça marche un peu comme une
chorégraphie en fait oui ça m'a fait un
peu peur qu'on me disait tout à l'heure
c'était mouvement artistique né beaucoup
de monde utilisent c'était un mélange
aussi de la dynastie qu on travaille
aussi à salto pendant le mouvement base
des mouvements solo donc à beaucoup
donc tout ça on pouvait apprendre dans
la capitale dans un cas pareil c'est pas
que les gens etc
c'était la danse qu'il arrive il fait la
danse mais comme moi on élève l'asie a
pas mal à m'en a dit du mouvement des
coquillages et à thouars du coup qui a
des bons temps doit on au début on
oblige on ne travaille pas beaucoup la
souplesse me demande si nécessaire se
place dans son usine à sa place à ce
travail pendant qu'au bout d'un moment
tu vas te confirmer travailler comme la
leur on enlève là aujourd'hui
bâtissez là il ya six ans déjà de kapo a
donc là est-ce que vous pouvez nous
montrer de trois mouvements comme ça
assez ou pas oui mon bras et qu'apprend
on vous laissera retourner aux journées
à la rencontre internationale à
elancourt hockey bien sûr mon agence on
improvise complètement alors je pense
toujours
alors je sais pas si on vous voit bien
peut-être donner plus la voit la super
voilà ok vous réponse est oui avait dit
allez y mettez vous à l'aise qu'on casse
rien il faut sa fonte font pas c'est pas
mal ok bon meilleures bases que ce temps
on démonte c'était la gigue carrelage il
est comme ça on fait là bas
on écarte un peu les jambes hockey
derrière on voit son monde
par ailleurs trois scénarii et là devant
avec le bras de m
ok ok démons du moment après on fait
veut faire petit défense jeter en bas au
québec et défend son ardeur donc tu
défense plus de mouvements du côté de
vous
c'est ça qui est difficile à 7 coups de
pied l'argument évoqué après c'est au
nom de contenus comment j'ai peur c'est
bon là il va merci beaucoup merci à vous